i'm sorry sad to hear about her majesty  um  i it was my particular hope that she  would see the century  um  because that would have been sensational  but uh  she's been queen all of my life  literally all of my life  and uh so it's  it's  it's a sad day but  i feel good about charles and welcoming  him to the throne so that's that  sir patrick stewart knighted by queen  elizabeth ii in 2010 now mourning the  monarch alongside the world  i was knighted by the queen i got my obe  from prince charles  and they never tell you who's going to  be because there is a number of them who  all do awards  and i was just kind of hoping it would  be i'd met her a couple of times  that it might be her and it was and  there were only two of us getting knight  hoods the other man was first and then  me and  and she was lovely and i feel  i feel um  i i feel her death and uh  it's it's um an important day  in the uk certainly  [Music]